[Music]
this is the BBC home service and here is
a special bulletin read by Simon Clarke
d-day has come early this morning the
Allies began the assault on the
northwestern face of Hitler's European
fortress the first official news came
just after half-past nine when supreme
headquarters of the Allied expeditionary
force issued communicate number one this
said under the command of General
Eisenhower allied naval forces supported
by strong air forces began landing
allied armies this morning on the
northern coast of France the Allied
commander in chief General Eisenhower
has issued an order of the day addressed
to each individual of the Allied
expeditionary force in it he said your
task will not be an easy one your enemy
is well trained well equipped and
battle-hardened he will fight savagely
but this is the year 1944 the tide has
turned the free men of the world are
marching together to victory On June 6th
1944 the world awoke to earth shattering
news Allied forces led by Britain and
America had begun the invasion of
Hitler's Europe by the end of this day
156,000 Allied troops were on French
ground supported by 6939 vessels with
over 14,000 674 sorties by aircraft
throughout the day within five days
54,000 186 vehicles and 104,000 428 tons
of supplies were transported on land
these factories came together to form
perhaps the most audacious invasion in
the history of humankind two years of
research development and planning
culminated in a day that we associate
with chaos and violence but little
consideration is ever made for the
carefully choreographed procedure that
made this day in the end an iconic day
of success this is the
mystics of d-day two years prior to
d-day on the 19th of August 1942 allied
Canadian forces attempted to land here
in Dieppe some 135 kilometers away from
the beaches of Normandy and suffered a
humiliating defeat the Allies expecting
the element of surprise to be enough to
win the battle made critical strategic
mistakes lack of communication
inadequate surveying of the beaches
gradient and geology poor planning of
routes inland along with little
knowledge of German fortifications led
to a complete rout of the four thousand
nine hundred and sixty-three men
that landed on the beaches of Dieppe
nine hundred and sixteen Canadian
soldiers were killed and around two
thousand four hundred and fifty were
wounded with many of those also being
taken as prisoners of war lack of
communication between the commanders at
sea and the men on the beach led to
additional landing craft have been sent
in when there was no space to land the
29 tanks that managed to land were
barely able to move in the loose shingle
beaches often digging trenches with
their tracks and becoming stuck only 15
of these tanks made it into the town
where their guns were too weak to take
on the strong German fortifications with
little to no air support or naval
artillery they were doomed to failure
but this failure would form the textbook
of what not to do in an amphibious
assault and lay the groundwork for d-day
in this episode of the logistics of
d-day we are going to explore the
science and logic in choosing the
beaches of Normandy as their landing
location the Allies controlled the seas
giving them immense power in deciding
where to begin their attack d-days goal
was to create a new western front to
ease pressure on the Soviets fighting a
bitter war on the Eastern Front and
spread the Axis powers even thinner as
the Americans pushed up from the south
in Italy to do this the Allies needed to
open a new Atlantic front coastline
stretching from Norway to the South of
France were considered and juggling the
myriad of factors into choosing a
location was never going to be an easy
task
in an ideal world the allies would have
chosen beaches closest to Great Britain
like those of Calais and Dunkirk this
would satisfy some of the primary
requirements for the invasion the short
sea crossing would ease the shipment of
supplies and personnel across the
English Channel and it was within range
of even the shortest range of Allied
fighters like the Spitfire a vital
requirement even though the Luftwaffe
was well defeated by DZ air support
would play a pivotal role in d-day
operations from landing power troopers
attacking coastal fortifications
disrupting reinforcements patrolling
shipping lanes towing gliders and
distributing supplies the range of
Allied fighters was a major logistical
concern and while Calais and Dunkirk
were the best locations in terms of
distance the Germans were all too aware
of this and had erected strong
fortifications and focused the brunt of
their forces in these areas these areas
were avoided for this reason but the
defense's stretched far beyond just
Calais a vast line of Defense's had been
hurriedly built stretching from the
Spanish border all the way to the north
of Norway consuming 17 million cubic
metres of concrete and 1.2 million tons
of steel enough concrete and steel to
construct over 150 of these gigantic
flak towers that the Nazis constructed
to protect their major cities this
material was used to create thousands of
smaller bunkers and trenches up and down
the coast with the greatest
concentrations been found near vital
ports like share Berg Antwerp and Brest
because this was the next requirement to
ensure success any invasion would be
short-lived without a steady supply of
equipment and Men the Allies had early
contingency plans with massive temporary
harbors that were erected directly onto
the chosen beaches but as we will learn
in future episodes these would not
satisfy the needs share Berg was
identified as a key port of interest
primarily due to its location on the
Cotentin Peninsula a peninsula which
could be cut off from reinforcements and
captured early here Normandy was the
clear choice
both within Fighter range and in close
proximity to shurberg Normandy was
quickly becoming the prime contender for
Operation Overlord but the job was
nowhere near finished and Normandy could
have been dropped for alternatives
Normandy needed to have suitable geology
and terrain and to determine this was
going to require an immense
information-gathering effort and the
Allies used every tool in their arsenal
to ensure their strategy would lead to
success this sometimes was as simple as
requesting holiday photos and postcards
from pre-war trips from citizens but
this information clearly wasn't enough
to plan an invasion and two years before
d-day a massive aerial reconnaissance
campaign began to survey the Atlantic
coast probing for weak points and
gathering strategic information
the RAF 140 squadron were tasked with
high-flying photo reconnaissance
missions equipped with Spitfires
modified with F 52 cameras
fitted just below and behind the wings
they were to photograph all coastal
defences from Calais to share Berg
photographing potential locations for
temporary airfields surveying
transportation links in France
identifying German fortifications and
assessing the gradients of each
potential Beach on that stretch of coast
the Allies were determined not to make
the same mistakes as Dieppe and this
would require the beaches geology to be
assessed to ensure their tanks and
equipment could be transported inland
for the first wave of attacks their work
was cut out for them avoiding German
anti-aircraft fire and fighters was just
one challenge getting the incredibly
specific conditions needed to determine
the gradient of the beaches was another
in order to determine the gradient of
the beaches several photos had to be
taken one with an average low tide one
with an average high tide and four
pictures at various points between the
two extremes this would give several
elevation data points to inform us of
the beaches gradient if this wasn't hard
enough winds could not be greater than
37 km/h to avoid surge tides interfering
with results they needed to take the
photos during sunset or so
rise in order to get decent contrast
between the water and the beach and they
needed a clear day with no clouds
obscuring the view these photos were
combined with title information to
create detailed charts of beach
gradients and lence along with high and
low water marks and thankfully
Normandy's beaches were found to have a
favorable gradient Normandy had a lot
going first it was relatively poorly
defended was within range of Allied
fighters had a short sea crossing which
would allow for a quick turnaround of
supply ships the English Channel had
only two relatively narrow entry points
which would be more easily defended from
u-boats
and the beaches would be shielded from
the worst of strong Atlantic winds by
the Cotentin Peninsula Normandy was
quickly becoming the primary contender
for the invasion now it was time for
fine detail planning Beach gradient info
was not enough
the chosen beaches needed to be capable
of bearing the load of heavy tanks and
vehicles that would eventually land
there this could not be done with planes
this needed men on the ground about six
months prior to d-day on a moonless New
Year's Eve major Logan Scott Bowden and
Sergeant Bruce Ogden Smith of the Royal
Engineers boarded a boat that would
bring them within a quarter mile of Gold
Beach one of the final British landing
sites from there they swam ashore where
they quickly took samples of the beach
using a metal augur and swam back
through heavy surf to return the samples
for analysis the Allies knew ahead of
time that these beaches would be
suitable characterized by medium grain
sand to fine-grained sand or mud would
result in the heavy equipment sinking
and to course a grain made it difficult
to maneuver
medium was just right these samples
however ultimately let the British know
that provisions would need to be taken
to overcome the softer than expected
scent many of the tanks on d-day came
with modifications to allow them to deal
with the terrain they would encounter
many Churchill tanks were fitted with
these carpet lane spools that would lay
over soft sand to increase the surface
area over which the pressure was being
exerted they could also be used to lay
over barbed wire defenses
others were fitted with simple rolls of
wood which could be dropped into
anti-tank trenches to allow traversal
much more cost-effective than these
early tests wasting two tanks to fill a
ditch this wasn't the only geology the
Allies needed to consider suitable
locations for temporary runways needed
to be identified this would require long
stretches of flat firm ground with
excellent drainage very close to the
original landing sites
the Calvados plateau located here
consisted of limestone covered in sand
deposited by the last ice age over a
thousands of years acidic rainwater
created thousands of underground
drainage holes sinkholes and caves
allowing any rainwater to drain quickly
this area was perfect and several
airstrip sprang up within days of the
first landings like some Pierre Duma
which began construction on d-day plus
one and finished construction on d-day
plus to the 8th of June it witnessed a
constant stream of aircraft coming in
for fuel ammunition and repairs while
also serving as an evacuation zone for
the injured in the month that followed
d-day the front line progressed only 19
kilometers from this point and it was a
vital supply point for the advancing
army this was just one of many advanced
landing grounds that were created over
the course of the campaign each serving
as a valuable forward base to allow the
Allies to gain air superiority in the
immediate vicinity patrolling roads and
attacking German strongholds to allow
the progress of the frontline these
supply line logistics will be fleshed
out more in a future episode ultimately
Normandy was chosen because it had the
right mix of geology had the port of
shurberg close enough to capture but
also had suitable alternative supply
options until those days came the
English Channel made it easier to defend
against German u-boat ports in Norway
Germany and along the west coast of
France this may have been heavily
defended too but as we will see in the
next episode of the logistics of d-day
which is available exclusively on nebula
a lies deception tactics would play a
vital role in making the Germans doubt
Normandy as the chosen location the next
three episodes of this series is now
available for you to watch Anna
episode 2 deals with deception tactics
episode 3 with the methods the Allies
used to blow a hole in the wall of
fortress Europe and episode 4 explores
the landing craft that landed hundreds
of thousands of men vehicles and
supplies directly onto the beaches there
are many more episodes to come over the
next couple of months and the best way
to watch them is by signing up to
curiosity stream which is now only
$11.99 for the entire year for that
$11.99 you will get access to all the
fantastic award-winning documentaries on
curiosity stream and get access to
nebula bundled with it for free
uh nebula you will get access to this
series along with many more original
series from Wendover productions tears
ooh and City Beautiful my new favorite
is Tom Scott's fantastic new game show
money nebula started just a few months
ago and is now transformed into a
legitimate streaming platform that has
allowed creators like me to experiment
more freely with our videos without
worries of punishment from the YouTube
algorithm if that sounds like something
you want to support head on over to
curiosity stream comm Ford slash real
engineering to get your year-long access
for just 1199
you